[Music]  [Laughter]  [Music]  according to YouTube's press page over a  billion people visit YouTube every month  this month today to be precise you are  one of those people what at all 1  billion plus of those humans you us and  your favorite creators included join  forces to achieve something incredible  and what if that achievement not only  immediately made our shared world better  for each of us but it also made the  world better for all of us  restoring our forests is the most  effective natural solution to the  climate crisis let's join forces right  now all billion plus of us and reforest  our beautiful world leave us a comment  share this video and most importantly  visit team trees org to take action and  to save trees across the planet  you